LINEUP.
HE'S GOT FAMILY AND FRIENDS
THROUGHOUT.
SO HE WILL BE FULL OF ENERG FOR
UP, TAKES A LOOK AND SHOOTS IT
IN.
ALONGRE ABLE TO GO UNDERNEATH
KAMPF AND ABOVE BRODIE.
THIS PASS HE
TORONTO'S LINE, MITTELSTÄDT
KNOCKS IT DOWN, TO.
>> Bryan: LEADS THE NHL IN SHOTS
ON GOAL.
NOTWO.
COMING OFF SIDE, LEAFS
BUFFALO.
FOUND A HOME IN BUFFALO, THOUGH
AS HE IS A STARAM
NYLANDER CALLED BANK, BUT THAT'S
WHERE YOU LIKE W LEAFS ARE TAKI
SMILE.
>> Mike: HE CAN'T BELIEVE
CIRCLE.
WORKS IT DOWN LEFT
IN THEIR LEGS.
A MINUTE IN STEP INSIDE
LYUBUSHKIN.
THAT'S WAY TOO EASY AND THE  TO
CORNER AND HAS THEMICHAEL BUNTI
THROUGH CRAIG ANDERSON,  COLLEC
OF HANDCUFFED HIM A LITTLE BIT
BUT HE MADE THE
SENDS IT ACROSS.
TRIED TO PULL THE TRIGGER BUT HE
TRIED TO FEED BUNTING.HIS FIRST
HOCKEY LEAGUE.
>> Mike: AUSUS BACK OU
LOOKS LIKE A BETENDS IT
FOR MTURNOVER.
MITCH MARNER AN  THE ICING, TURN
THE PUCK OVER AND END T BUFFALO
PARENTS GET A GREAT CHANCE TO
WATCH HIM PLAY AND